[Music]
i love to
prove people along
and i think that
perseverance has stuck with me from very
early age
despite my disability
i still want to
tackle everything head-on
my name is kyle peace
red peace is my older brother
brae and i
do
a dirty sport together
when i'm late
i
get a feeling of freedom
kyle is a [ __ ] quadriplegic so all
four limbs are affected by his cerebral
palsy that confines kyle to a wheelchair
what i always try to picture when i'm
racing with kyle is him getting out of a
chair and coming behind me and just
giving me that slight push you know when
you've been in those endurance races or
those moments where you just don't feel
like there's anything more to give you
know sometimes that little push is all
you need and kyle's usually there to
give it
where
and i always had to think about
brent was always the
the big brother the overprotected
brother
what are you doing what has always
equated me every activity
whether it was baseball or
soccer we were always on the same team
when we graduated from college i got on
this path to personal fitness and i was
actually running a lot at the time and i
built up to an iron man
after that first iron man in 2010 kyle
began figuring out how he could get
involved and you know at one point the
infamous question he said was can people
in wheelchairs do iron man and so that
just created this instant spark
i said to kyle one time i'll provide the
legs if he provides the spirit and
that's really how it's always gone
we slowly built up the process so we
started with a 10k running race and then
we did a half marathon and then we did
our first triathlon and then we trained
for this ironman hawaii in 2018
when i did the ironman world
championship it was the hardest thing
that i have ever done
mentally at physically
it's a 2.4 mile swim followed by a
hundred twelve mile bike
and then you do a 26.2 marathon all in
one day and they give you 17 hours
when i did it in 14 hours it's 29
minutes
the feeling when i go out to finish
drawing was truly amazing
to accomplish something with somebody
that you love
that you care about is really special
[Music]
i love my brother to death
he's helped me do incredible things
i would have never been in hawaii
without him i wouldn't be doing the
boston marathon without him
he's led me on this incredible journey
when you see him out there competing
he's just as intense if not more than
everybody that's out there i mean i
always think back to that new york
marathon when he just had this fire in
his eyes and he said you can quit but
i'm going to keep going there's this
intensity about him
in racing that is hard to match
i need kyle's energy i need his spirit
i'm not going to stop nobody's going to
stop me i think it's the point that we
all
take a step back and focus on what we
have rather than what we don't have and
focus on the hope to persevere through
any obstacle that might come
my way
or your way
[Music]
you